こんにちははじめ社長です今日はリクエストで俺のお母さんからの俺のお母さんの友達
の息子さんだな
リクエストみたいな感じで社長ちょっと付に失敗した人へのメッセージみたいなを下さ
いって言われたんで今日はず県失敗してない人ほどこれから受験
ふととか全く関係ない人ちょっとよかったと聞いてくださいって感じでございます俺の
受験失敗談と恋愛の話です
あんまり俺さんの恋愛のお話とかあんまりしないからねぇ
まぁたまにはこういうのもいいかなと思ってさまず僕ですねぇまぁ大学受験ハ
失敗の
カテゴリーに入ります図形は失敗しましたね未だ話すのは完全に僕が youtube
始める前の頃の話です
僕にとってやる結構恋愛と受験は結構でかい結びつきがあったんですよっての高校自体
はまあ2つのワードやラースとバスケと彼女
この人でしかもなかったですマジで基本的に部活はもう毎日だったんでバスケずっ
としてて高1の最初に彼女ができたんですよ後々3年間つ今日は来ずになるんですけど
も一人の彼女が出来て基本がステップガンガンやってって感じ
億万一緒に帰ったりしてたんですけどもまぁ皆さん知っての通り僕はですね
技なんです
いや前菜だよ天才とバカは紙一重だから一概にパパとは言えないけどどっちかというと
バカなんです
天才だけどねだが天才といる勉強ができなかったのかな
勉強があんまり好きな方じゃなかったですでチェストとかもそんな超低いわけじゃない
んですけども全然も50点のか40分とかそういう感じをとっててでは僕の彼女はまあ
基本的に結構勉強ができたり体スーツが出したり結構人としてしっかりしたんですよ
いや俺がしっかりしてなかったわけじゃないけどね上数でバブ彼女さん結構なんだろう
しっかり勉強したり体すると私つって感じで僕はもちゃんプロ捨ててもうバス停した人
でバスケか謎
上にみたいな感じでずっと公平なヘマしてねまあ過ごしてたわけですよこういう家の
初期の頃に付き合ってのバスケと彼女でこうにも出すけど彼女お父さんもバスケと彼女
のでバス今日ねしっかりやっててその辺の弱い高校と彼にはもう100点差つけて買っ
たりしてましたねこう提出物を出さないで成績悪い摩耗粉ずらずらと高3の春まで来た
んですけども
なーこーさんと言ったらもあるでしょう引退試合ですベスト16ぐらいまで登れたん
ですけどもまぁわずかに及ばず一体ということになってしまいました
ジャズ部活は一生懸命やってたんでガッツあっ
んですけどもう空意見は引退しちゃったんで高3の春はまぁちょっと彼女だけみたいな
感じがちゃいますよ
ちょっとだけで52かなーっもうちょっと覚えてないんですけどさ登校中はほぼ毎日
一緒に行ってましたね違う方向から学校に行ってるんですけどもそこはもう愛の力
ティっなんとか間違っに入ってました本当に子どもなんでも出来るって思ってたらた
て僕はね僕はさんな音グイグイいけるような奴じゃなかったってのはこう社員に
おとなしく人に投稿したり一緒に帰ったりしたという感じです
まあこのときの僕の間そのままステータスを話し待つとまぁ真面目です勉強ができます
呈するつ完璧に出しますほぼ正ボランティアもつけてまあそれに対して僕はまあバス停
のみ勉強はほぼ出来ません提出物購入の時は一家
を出しませんですか踏まず目ではなかったんですけどもあんまりこうしっかりして釣れ
なかったですね
でも彼女が大切と毎年愛に生きる男ってやつですよねまあ鉱山の初期なんですけども僕
の彼女
勉強もできてボランティアをして停止するとも出してるお前らこれがないように
見せかけるそう
推薦です力をしっかりしてる人たちはね
それが評価されて推薦入試というねまあ一般受験とは違う面接とかで大学に入ることが
出来るんですねそんな彼女はもう見るからこういうパーフェクトな感じだったんで
案の定推薦を先生から勧められておりました焦る北長谷何こりゃまずいと僕結構
負けず嫌いだったんですよちょっとこう
ちょっと強がりたいところだったんだよこれじゃあ彼女
に負けちゃうと思って結構彼女が説明られたところが結構いいところだったんですよ
それを取れば県からちょっと離れちゃうそこで僕は思ったんですがこのまま the
一緒にれなくなっちまう彼女の特にちまうそんなネイラーペンを持ってまぁちょっと
一生懸命勉強しようかなって思いましたね
その時はまだこれといってしたいことがなかったのでとりあえずなるべく彼女と近い
とこ
いきたいなと思ってこれも勉強取得すかねーなって感じで言えば高3の部活終わって
すぐぐらいから結構本気で勉強を始めました
配置状況で高3の夏の始まりですが僕本当にバスケしかしてなかったんで勉強本当に
できなかったです言えばターってやつですバカなんでもまだはバカなりに本気で気合
入れて勉強を始めました夏休みはまあ1日最低10時間は確実にしていたと思います
彼女のかと思えば寝ようユースやビジネス10時間くらい待っプライドもあったんです
けどね僕の中ので高3の夏からコツコツ勉強会
頑張ってまぁ秋ごろにはね進研ゼミといろんなもしがあったんですけどもまぁその中で
も結構江南市とか
総合田チートが学校の中ではそこそこ路線ました時点は全国バトルなんでなんとも言え
ないですけどそんなってライナーも僕の頭の中はずっと彼女と過ごせる日アクセルって
いうのをこっそり思い浮かべて
たわけです何だろうなんか誰かのために大学受験するっていうのは変な話なんですけど
超行きたいみたいだ大学はなかったんだなんで一番いいの朝の彼女の近くで好きなこと
ができる大学にいければ一番いいなっていう感じで代読選びしていましたてか絶対
行こうとしてもスッとに感じでは凸コツコツクズ勉強してまー成績もなかなかいい感じ
に登って
まあ行きたい所がいけるかなって感じだったんですけども大学入手ないですね結構で
推薦入試って合格発表か早くて僕座に石している時にもう僕の他の所
推薦で合格をもらってますかこれはねー
僕ん中で焦ったんですよいいところがちょっと決まっちゃって
アップ口の中ちょっと焦りというかパパだがやばいやばい
決まってしまったみたいなちょっといろいろまえ燃やすていることだってまぁやべぇと
同じで止めると彼女期末打って俺もどうすればいいんだこの文便所つ本当に受かるのか
ポントラブルどうぞ始めとなりつつも
まぁ結局一般入試2が勉強するしかないんですよ当時全員定数を出した奴が受かるって
いうシンプルなシステム
んですそれでもう本当に秋ごろからは勉強しかしなくなりますねのと飯食いをぐらい
しか時間とはなかったですあなた全部勉強ですお風呂の中でもずっと
漢文の単語を覚えてましただいぶこれで結構でもガッツがついたんですよ勉強
ボケが本気で勉強してる間僕の体はまあ文句ひとつ言わず静かになってくるわけですよ
校推薦で知ってるかっ
ちょいとワーって何か一部で喜んじゃってちょっと嫌な気持ちになると思うんですよ
一般の人
はい提言を迎えましたセンター試験当日でございます当日はね正しく大失敗といけです
よ直前に行った店セール150分実は下がっててちょっと
彼女の近くの大学は厳しい感じかなと思ったんです
それでも僕は
出たかったんですよその大学落ちたら落ちたで僕は良いかなと思ってそこが僕の行き
たいところだったので感じたことをまあ親に話しても親はいいよとあんたの好きなとこ
を受けさせてあげるっていう感じで結構前向きだったんですけども
なぜか学校に止められましたね大画家エレベーターで
大外から選べたんですけどもボケが行きたい所が結構厳しい感じだったんとマー物工的
にはやっぱちゃんと合格させたかったんでしょねそこでは受けさせてくれませんでした
僕もその代表としか見えてなかったんで学校は俺をさんと降格させたいからそこに受け
させないで俺のお母さんはあんたの舌だから好きなところを受けが再生
それでまあ担任と木刀お母さんに話していたんですけども絶対僕は買いたくなかった僕
の
[音楽]
うか妻が子が俺の人生を決めるわけじゃねえとまぁお母さんどこにいっていうことも
分かったんですけども
学校側としてはこの学校の制度の僕ワーク学校の意向で従ってほしいちょっとアーマー
よく覚えてないんですけれどもそういう感じだったんですよなぁものすごい言い合いに
なったんですけども結局
志望校には受けさせてもらえますよ多分でも受けてても落ちた
と思いますあの点数だったらその時初めて学校でいただきましたねなんか人生が他人に
取られるすごい嫌ですよねまあね結局僕が本当に行きたかった大学たちが大学を受けて
何とかまぁ合格して今に至るんですけどもどうですか今話聞いて受験失敗ってこんな
感じです
静雄結局でそんな彼女とはちょっと遠い場所にあって毎日し
に豚切って学校行って手前にちゃってたのかちょっと裏目にでたんですけども向こうが
ちょっと無理だと
by さえないのはちょっとつらいということで別れました
大学1年生と最初の頃ですね早速いただけましては3年間ですよ
結婚とも考えてましたからね徒歩で始動この人と一緒にいるんだなって感じでずっと
この時しておいたんで2日間くらい泣いてマジでつらかったです
あの時は本当は行きたい大学に見せずに3年間付き合った彼女にフられすべて失った
感じでしたね
まぁそこでねバーイ
僕もいろいろ考えてあなたにのほうかも結構彼女のペットを考えたりしてなんですよ2
の幸せな生活をご存知なんですけれどもそういうことを色々買ってね色々僕の中で考え
て一番大事なんだ俺じゃねぇかなと
これを人生とするのは俺なんだよ俺を第一に考えるようになりましたそれからなんか自
骨へたちょっと違うんですよ
自己中とは違うんですけども本気
分のことを大事にするようになりましたねそんなこんなで麻痺は変わり図形は失敗し
外出でしたんですけども今があります
dive dive 方向はずれた機種ので web 方がずれなんですけどもまぁ今
帰って元気にね毎日楽しく生きてますあぁ僕が言いたかったのは何だろうな
受験失敗したからってあんまり落ち込まなくていいです死ぬわけじゃない
4受験だけじゃないんや大好きな恋人に振られたりよくないことがあってもそれしない
訳じゃありませんすぐこと以外は彼氏考えよって今年では要するにというボケの花って
何結論にたどり着いていました
どうですか月に失敗した人励まされましたか
はいされてないですねこんな感じは高校時代を送ってたわけですできない
今から受験する人は本気で勉強してみてください見ないと思っつは殺せないけど意味
ないことでしっかり頑張れる奴って誰も強いですか
意味ないことすら頑張れのやつは意味あることも頑張れませんたとどっかに停まります
2勉強とかそういうちょっとっ楽しくないことをしっかり頑張る奴はマズい
急いでも頑張れるんじゃないかなって思います事は
ぶーぶーとんちー
[音楽]
ん